we have armed objective apples war is
hell
luckily for you we have five fun-filled
ways to stay alive and get some in
battlefield ones open beta have you ever
wondered who would win in a game of
chicken between a horse and a plane I'll
give you a hint it's the one with more
horsepower
one of my favorite things to do in the
game is slicing and dicing my enemies on
my trusty Steve you're a force to be
reckoned with against infantry not just
because you can carve them up but
because you can run them over I mean
come on how many times can you say you
ran over somebody with a horse
nothing will teach your enemies to stay
the hell down better than getting hit in
the face with an artillery shell this
one man death on wheels will have your
enemies screaming for mercy before long
thank you safe on that cliff think
you'll be alright in that armored car
don't think I can get you from there
you're wrong
use the artillery tank it to your
advantage to help your team push towards
the enemy objective and give them proper
cover when taking on armored vehicles as
well combat knives are so last year time
to bust out your own saver once you
dismount your trusty steed you get to
keep the saber as a nice parting gift so
don't get caught bringing a knife to a
sword fight bring a saber instead if you
thought the trench tank was a beast
which you climb aboard this thing
mounting both artillery cannons and
heavy machineguns this nightmare on
tracks has the firepower to give you the
best chance to turn defeat into victory
in conquest all capture points aside
from F are within range of the trained
weapons and you can also go reversing
this thing to use the artillery to
attack the points and the machine guns
to defend against infantry trying to
rush and destroy the Train
and there you have it five fun-filled
ways to rain hell on your friends or
foes in battlefield ones open beta now
if you excuse me it's time for me to
ride off into the sunset
right after I kill this guy